bienvenidos de nuevo estamos empezando
la sección 4 del examen 4 y está bueno
es la parte 1 que por cierto estamos en
la pagina 594 así que pues empecemos una
vez y vamos ser el problema número uno y
el problema número uno me dice lo
siguiente si x menos y es igual a 8 voy
a ponerlo aquí si x menos esto es igual
a 8 y después y es igual a 13 está y es
igual a tres veces z y después nos dicen
que z es igual a 2 entonces lo que me
preguntan es el valor de x yo lo que
quiero saber es cuánto vale x pero
nosotros ya sabemos que se está vale 2
si se trata de 2 entonces lo puedo meter
aquí y me va a quedar que ya es igual a
3 por zetas que es lo mismo que tres por
dos lo cual es 6 y sí que vale 6
entonces ya lo puedo sustituir en esta
ecuación de que arriba sigue vale 6
entonces me va a quedar que x menos 6
esto es igual a 8 y si sumo 6 de ambos
lados de esta ecuación me va a quedar
x es igual a 86 lo cual es lo mismo que
14 x es igual a 14 y por cierto este es
el inciso
este es el inciso m
z es igual a 2 y yo creo que estoy
repitiendo lo mismo
perdona creo que me estoy volviendo cada
vez un poco más viejo
así problema número 2 problema número 2
y dice tomás es más viejo que marta pero
es más joven que susana thomas es más
viejo que marta si tomás supongamos que
tiene te años entonces la edad de tomás
es más grande que la edad de marta
porque tomás es más viejo que marta por
lo tanto tiene más años que marta pero a
su vez es más joven que susana por lo
tanto es más joven tiene menos años que
susana dice o de hecho creo que este
problema de manera inversa ya está si
que es la edad de tomás m es la edad de
marta y ese es la edad de susana justo
lo que puso aquí entonces cuál de las
siguientes desigualdades es cierta y ya
está es justo este de aquí tomás tiene
más edad que marta y susana tiene más
edad que tomás y por lo tanto tenemos
esta desigualdad que tenemos justo aquí
por cierto es el inciso a así de fácil
estaba esta pregunta muy bien
creo que tengo espacio de escribir el
problema número tres
a ponerlo aquí problema número 3 dice si
el área de dos regiones es la misma
vamos a suponer que es la región 1 y la
región 2 entonces el área de la región 1
es igual al área de la región 2 el área
de la región 1 es la misma que el área
de la región 2 y la suma de ambas áreas
es 5 a la suma de estas dos y 5 de gm en
verde color el área 1 más el área 2 esto
es igual a 5 lo que me pregunta es cuál
es el promedio de estas áreas pero bueno
esto está muy fácil porque si el área 1
es igual al área 2 entonces en lugar del
área 2 puedo poner el área 1 y me va a
quedar que dos veces el área 1 esto es
igual a 5 o dicho de otra manera el área
1 es igual a 5 entre 2 que es 2.5 y el
área 1 vale 2.5 de igual manera el área
2 vale 2.5 porque las dos áreas son
iguales y lo que me preguntan es cuál es
el promedio de estas dos áreas y bueno
pues la respuesta es muy sencilla es 2.5
sitios de tomás
promete de estas dos y lo divides entre
dos como son dos datos iguales entonces
la suma de estos dos entre dos pues es
lo mismo que esto y de hecho lo puedes
ser tú mismo podría sumar 2.5 2.5 y
dividirlo entre 2 y vas a llegar a 2.5
eso si no me crees de todas maneras si
tenemos dos datos iguales y quiero sacar
su promedio es el valor de uno de esos
datos
y esta es la respuesta de hecho tengo
2.5 2.5 es lo mismo que dos enteros un
medio y esto es lo mismo que 2 por 24
más 15 medios cinco medios que es el
inciso de perfecto entonces ya tengo el
problema 123 déjame borrar la pantalla y
vamos a poner ahora el problema número 4
el problema número 4 y dice sea ese es
el conjunto de todos los enteros
posibles que se puedan escribir como n
cuadrada más uno
esos importantes déjenme encontrarlo por
aquí
s el conjunto de todos los enteros de la
forma n cuadrada más 1 n cuadrada más 1
y por cierto me dice el conjunto de
todos los enteros posibles que se pueden
escribir de esta forma donde n es un
entero no negativo déjame quitar esto
aquí n es un entero no negativo n
entonces tiene que ser mayor que 0 muy
bien y tiene que ser entero
pero perfecto eso es lo que me dice este
problema y lo que me preguntan es cuál
de los siguientes enteros está en ese
bueno antes de irme para ver cuáles son
los enteros que están en ese vamos a
explorar un poco cuáles son los enteros
que pueden estar en ese va a ser una
tabla que pasa con n y que vamos a ver
qué pasa con los enteros que estén en s
es decir n cuadrada más 1
n puede valer 1 2 3 4 a 5 o 6 vamos a
ver qué pasa 5 o 6 etcétera y quienes en
el cuadrado más 1 bueno tiene vale 1
entonces uno al cuadrado es uno más uno
me quedaría 2 si en el ballet 2 entonces
2 al cuadrados 41 me da 5 100 de val de
entonces encuadrada más 1 es 91 que es
10 tiene vale 4 me quedaría 16 más 1 que
es 17 y date cuenta que ya estamos
entendiendo qué es lo que pasa con este
conjunto ese nosotros nos fijamos en un
cuadrado perfecto ya es el cuadrado
perfecto le sumamos 1 por ejemplo aquí
sería 25 más unos es 26 y aquí tengo 36
más uno sería 37 es decir todos los
cuadrados perfectos le sumamos 1 y
entonces vamos a ver nuestras posibles
respuestas tengo en el inciso am tengo
en el inciso 16 16 es un cuadrado
perfecto pero no es un cuadrado perfecto
más 1 por lo tanto
en el inciso b en el inciso b me queda
28 28 es lo mismo que a 3 por 3 por 3 3
por 3 9 por 3 27 27 128 pero 27 no es un
cuadrado perfecto es un cubo perfecto
pero no es un cuadrado perfecto por lo
tanto este no me sirve vamos a ver el
inciso 6 35 a 35 es lo mismo que 36
menos 1 pero aquí lo que nosotros
tenemos que hacer es sumarle 1 y
entonces está tampoco es mi respuesta
correcta el inciso de me dice 39 39 de
plano no sé ni por dónde están 39 es
tres unidades más que seis al cuadrado a
mí creo que está no me sirve y por
último el inciso m tengo 50
y fíjate en el 50-50 si funciona porque
es lo mismo que 7 al cuadrado más 1 es
decir 49 1 si aquí nosotros hacemos un
número más que 7 me quedaría 7 por 7 es
decir 7 al cuadrado que es 49 más 1 me
daría 50 es la respuesta de este
problema el inciso y el inciso en 50 y
al final lo más importante de ese
problema era darse cuenta que estos
enteros que están en el conjunto ese es
exactamente lo mismo que un cuadrado
perfecto más uno muy bien ya está aquí
el problema número cuatro y vamos a
resolver el problema número cinco espero
que me queda aquí tengo una figura
parecida a ésta así que déjenme hacer
aquí la figura que tengo aquí en este
libro
tengo un círculo parecido a éste pero no
este no me gusta tengo un círculo
parecido a éste
muy bien es algo así perfecto y en este
círculo que me dan bueno me dan a un
triángulo dentro de él tengo aquí el
centro de este círculo y tengo un
triángulo que se ve más o menos así
déjeme que me dé color
tengo un triángulo que va más o menos
como por aquí voy a intentar hacerlo lo
más parecido al dibujo y tengo otro lado
por acá y después tengo este que los une
muy bien este va para acá ok y después
tengo este punto tengo este otro punto
aquí toca la circunferencia y además me
dicen que este este ángulo vale x este
ángulo vale x mientras que este de camps
valley en este vale y ok y lo que me
preguntan es cuánto vale y si x si x es
igual a 40 grados a 40 grados y bueno si
x es igual a 40 grados entonces este
ángulo vale 40 grados 40
y si este ángulo vale 40 grados como
obtenemos el ángulo jim bueno pues
nosotros sabemos qué es lo que pasa con
los ángulos internos de un triángulo
pero cómo saber este otro ángulo y
seguramente si has visto todos los
problemas del st te va a saltar luego
luego a que la respuesta tiene que ver
con un triángulo isósceles porque date
cuenta que este lado este lado es
exactamente igual que este lado como
sabemos eso porque este lado es un radio
y este lado es un radio también y en un
círculo todos sus radios son iguales por
lo tanto este radio es exactamente igual
a este radio o dicho de otra manera este
lado es igual a este otro lado este lado
y este lado son iguales y por lo tanto
si este lado es igual a este lado
estamos hablando de un triángulo
isósceles un triángulo isósceles que
tiene dos lados iguales y si tenemos dos
lados iguales entonces nosotros sabemos
que este ángulo este ángulo de aquí y
este ángulo de aquí también son iguales
este ángulo también vale
y si también vale james entonces ya
puedo obtener el valor de 10 porque
porque yo sé que yo más bien
mas x esto tiene que ser igual a 180
grados
este más este más este los ángulos
internos de un triángulo tienen que ser
igual a 180 grados y de aquí me va a
quedar que 2 james más x pero x vale 40
grados más 40 esto es igual a 180 grados
y de aquí me va a quedar que dos ya es
igual a 140 grados o james es igual a 70
grados perfecto que es justo el valor
que yo quería lo que quería era saber
cuánto valía 10
llévales 70 grados lleva los 70 grados y
lo descubrimos dándonos cuenta que esté
en un triángulo isósceles por cierto es
el inciso de entonces ya está aquí el
problema número 5 y todavía me da tiempo
de hacer más problemas vamos al problema
número 6 déjame borrar la pantalla y
ahora sí aquí está el problema número
seis un cuadrado simple es un entero
mayor que 1 que solamente tiene tres
factores enteros positivos
el mismo su raíz cuadrada y 1 cuál de
los siguientes es un cuadrado simple y
bueno
tengo aquí mis cinco opciones pero vamos
a analizar primero a qué me refiero
cuando hablo de un cuadrado simple
fíjate bien si yo tengo los primeros
números veamos 1 2 3 4 5 6 y al 1 lo
elevó al cuadrado me da 12 elevado al
cuadrado media 43 elevado al cuadrado me
da 9 4 elevado al cuadrado me da 16 525
y 636 date cuenta que el 1 su único
factor es 1 aquí vamos a poner los
factores factores factores y el 1 su
único factor es una aquí no hay tanto
problema el 4 sus únicos factores es 1 2
y 4 el mismo de 9 en un 9 pasa lo mismo
sus factores es 13 y 9 es decir la
unidad su raíz cuadrada y el mismo 16
por su parte sus factores es 1 2 4 8 y
16 16 tiene muchos factores no solamente
es la unidad su raíz cuadrada y el mismo
la unidad su raíz cuadrada y el mismo
sino que además tiene al 2 y al 8 como
factores 25 por su parte tiene 1 a como
factor 5 como factor y 25 éste solamente
tienen tres factores mientras que el 36
por ejemplo tiene 123 tiene 4
quintano pero sexta sin séptima no 8
tampoco 9 9 por 4 36 10 no
11 no 12 sí
13 tampoco 14 tampoco 15 tampoco 16
tampoco 17 18 18 y por último 36 fíjate
que el 36 tiene además de el mismo su
raíz cuadrada y la unidad tiene un buen
de factores más por lo tanto yo voy a
decir que un número es un cuadrado
simple si es un número cuyos factores
son 3
por ejemplo el 4 cuyos factores son el
mismo la unidad y su raíz cuadrada este
sería un número que es un 4 a 2 simple
este también sería un número que es un
cuadrado simple y este también será un
número que es un cuadrado simple ok
entonces vamos a analizar nuestras
posibles respuestas el inciso
dice 121 121 esto es lo mismo que 11 al
cuadrado por lo tanto sus factores
pongamos aquí factores factores
a 111 y 121 se te ocurre alguno más creo
que no creo que son todos sus factores
no es divisible entre 3 ni entre 5 creo
que son todos los factores vamos a ver
el inciso b el inciso b es 100 100 bueno
siendo es lo mismo que 10 al cuadrado
por lo tanto sus factores es 110 100
pero también tiene como factores el 2
tiene como factor el 5 etcétera por lo
tanto como ya encontramos más de tres
factores el isis obed no es posible este
no es un número cuadrado simple veamos
el inciso c en el inciso c es 81 81
tienen como factores el 1 el 9 el 81
pero también el 33 por 39 por 3 27 por 3
81 entonces aquí pueden seguir y seguir
pero ya encontramos uno más de tres
factores y por lo tanto no me sirve
vamos a ver qué me dice el inciso de el
inciso de es 64 aquí se notan luego
luego
tampoco es un cuadrado simple porque
tiene como factores 1 a 8 x 8 64 64 pero
también tiene el 2 tiene al 4 etcétera
etcétera etcétera por lo tanto este no
es un cuadrado simple vamos a tacharlo y
por último tengo al inciso en que es 33
33 ni siquiera es un cuadrado perfecto
por lo tanto este luego luego lo podemos
tachar no es un cuadrado perfecto y
entonces mi respuesta es el shisha y ya
está no tengo más tiempo pero por ahora
voy a dejar este problema número 6 y
esta primera parte de el examen número 4
de la sección número 4 nos vemos en el
siguiente vídeo